bertrand legrand médecins généralistes
catherine hill épidémiologiste
bonsoir à tous les deux merci d'être
avec nous alors une une réaction tout
d'abord peut-être sur ce qu'on a appris
cet après midi l'elysée qui charge une
mission indépendante d'évaluer à la
gestion de la crise sanitaire c'est une
bonne chose bertrand legrand et bien
c'est comme toujours il va surtout
falloir savoir qui est dans la
commission parce que si on fait une
commission avec des personnes qui n'ont
pas une indépendance parfaite
ce sera compliqué donc faire des
commissions c'est bien agir c'est mieux
madame catherine c'est pas vraiment le
moment on est encore en plein dans
l'âpre la fin de la première vague
cette première vague n'est pas fini donc
on verra plus tard pour faire les
comptes et dire qu' on aurait pu faire
mieux et comme on aurait pu faire mieux
mais voilà je moi ça m'intéresse pas
beaucoup ça alors ça vous intéresse pas
mais tout de même il ya quand même un
voilà un soupçon qui flotte dans l'air
on a écouté évidemment l'audition du
didier raoul tu y est requis voilà qui
évoquer davantage de politiques moins de
6 ans didier raoul qui alliait qu'elle
est assez forte qui a visé les conflits
d'intérêts les laboratoire gilead
notamment ça vous a surpris vous
bertrand legrand vous que les histoires
de confit de laboratoire moi je fais pas
partie de ceux qui jettent la pierre aux
laboratoires ou inversement qui sont des
aficionados des de la pureté absolue
je pense que les laboratoires ont tout
intérêt à ce que la science avance et
donc du coup par définition ils
s'adressent à des spécialistes et ses
histoires de il faut absolument de pure
ne plus avoir aucun lien avec les
laboratoires nous ont conduit à
supprimer toutes les capacités de
formation de nos internes et qui
aujourd'hui peine bien avoir les
subsides de l'état pour obtenir le
financement de leur formation donc
l'état veut supprimer les subsides des
laboratoires sait très bien qu'ils
payent à sa place et là on se sera
parfait à catherine hill
sur ce point mais c'est évident que les
essais de des traitements ont été
catastrophiques en france qu'au fond on
n'a pas beaucoup de résultats à mettre à
table on peut comparer à ce qu'ont fait
les anglais ils ont fait un grand essai
dans lequel ils ont testé plusieurs
traitements et ils nous ont apporté
plusieurs résultats que la dexaméthasone
est utile et que l'hydroxyde coquine à
l'hôpital n'est pas vraiment utile
donc voilà il va falloir effectivement
faire le bilan de ça et penser à
réorganiser la façon de faire les études
de médicaments et le professeur raout a
démontré une compétence absolue dans
l'évaluation des médicaments ou bertrand
legrand vous vous partagez ce constat un
petit peu sévère la compétence
totalement dans l'évaluation des
médicaments il ya vraiment eu un voile
avait des failles dans ses systèmes
d'études selon vous également
il suffit de regarder le résultat qui
est produit aujourd'hui ce qu'elle
aimait de la médecine française a
produit ces aucune résultats
scientifiques
on s'est contenté d'un débat politique
pro ou anti raul complètement stérile
qui ferra rien et voilà on a deux camps
d'ayatollahs qui s'affrontent les uns
les autres et qui ne du coup ne
produisent ni dans un sens ni dans un
autre
aujourd'hui clairement parle d'une
deuxième vague on va pas citer
effectivement didier raoul toutes les
deux minutes mais c'est vrai qu'il nous
avait prédit voilà ce départ du virus
que le virus circulera mais qui bénit et
l'épidémie partir est bon maintenant il
envisage qu'elle revienne avec la
nouvelle zélande catherine ils vont vous
c'est toujours aussi inquiètes plus que
jamais je dirais je suis pas très
inquiète mais l'épidémie n'est pas
terminée donc on peut pas faire comme si
l'épidémie était fini il ya encore 500
cas par jour à peu près et on a vu que à
pékin après avoir eu zéro cas pendant
quatre semaines
tout d'un coup il ya eu de nouveaux 30
cas par jour et on a fait très attention
recombiner tester s'est désinfecté et
c'est ici on a ça sent capable on a tout
le monde s'en fiche complètement
donc l'épidémie n'est pas finie la
première vague
n'est pas fini le virus est là bertrand
legrand votre diagnostic également on
s'était vus plusieurs fois alors là
c'est vrai que la première fois vous
parliez de votre cabinet vous viviez ben
voila j'ai plus de cas en ville la
semaine d'après vous étiez un peu plus
mesuré
qu'en est il aujourd'hui vous avez quand
même l'impression aujourd'hui qu'il ya
un frein dans cette épidémie où vous
restez prudents et même inquiet
contrairement à madame lille moi je n'ai
la vision que de mon propre cabinet donc
forcément ma vision est très limité à un
quartier donc je ne peux pas avoir une
vision qui soit au niveau national ce
qui est certain c'est que manifestement
les chiffres montrent qu'effectivement
là de la première vague n'a pas été
terminé
et quand on sait que le l'épidémie est
partie de quelques cas c'est toujours
inquiétant de se dire qu'on relâche la
politique de test simple fait que nous
avons trop peu de mes de trop peu de
positif sur le nombre de tests que nous
faisons et on a l'impression d'être sur
un concours du de celui du pays qui aura
le plus de positif alors là dessus on
est gagnant parce qu'on fait tellement
peu de tests qu'on arrive à avoir plein
de positif on est super fort mais on est
super inutile surtout alors vous allez
être quand même contents tous les deux
olivier ferrand a évoqué une campagne de
tests virologiques de grande ampleur
pour identifier d éventuels cluster
dormant 1,3 million de personnes sont
concernées dans 30 communes alors
manifestement se demande ile de france
catherine hill vous êtes satisfait tout
s'est encore pas trop la bonne solution
pour vous à ce qui est la bonne solution
c'est de tester massivement la
population
le fond du problème c'est qu'il ya
énormément de veron il parle de kloster
dormant ça c'est un truc qui l'a inventé
je ne sais pas qu'est ce que c'est que
cette histoire
le sascoc 2 est un virus qui a la
propriété d'infecter des gens qui
restent asymptomatique et qui sont
contagieux
la règle de base d'une maladie
infectieuse qu'il faut trouver des gens
qui sont contagieux pour les isoler pour
qu'ils évitent qu'ils contaminent
d'autres gens et pour trouver ces gens
qui n'ont pas de symptômes
la seule façon c'est de tester tout le
monde
c'est ça qui a été fait dans sa sentence
tout le monde autour dans les régions où
on a une petite chance de tomber sera
porteur du virus par exemple en ile de
france
donc c'est une très bonne idée tester
tout le monde en ile de france c'est
juste un peu tard mais jamais trop tard
pour bien faire
donc on va tester en ile-de-france assez
massivement dans les communes où il ya
plus de chances d'avoir des porteurs de
virus
on pourrait tester encore plus largement
ça va peut-être venir
bertrand legrand a souvent entendu dire
bon bah voilà les tests les masques on
les a maintenant enfin ça sera peut-être
bon pour la prochaine fois c'est bien ça
effectivement de tester sur l'île de
france est la bonne stratégie d'olivier
veyrat la première stratégie c'était de
faire du trail du contact racing et donc
j'imagine que tous les personnes en
charge du contact et racing ont prescrit
des tests est ce qu'on aimerait bien
savoir c'est le taux de tests réalisés
par rapport au nombre de taux de tests
prescrits et de ce que j'en sais on
n'atteint pas le niveau de ce qu'on peut
avoir nous en cabine et quand on demande
à la personne vous voulez vous être
testés et consorts l'écouvillon et qu on
le teste donc circuits courts on a un
taux à 100% organisations étatiques
on aura un taux à 40 50 60 % donc la
meilleure méthode pour tester un grand
nombre de personnes c'est de fournir les
tests aux médecins généralistes de les
inciter à tester et d'organiser le
circuit de collecte des données pour
donner aux épidémiologistes les
résultats mais si on rate une seule de
ces pistes on rate ou alors que si on
fait des six ont prescrit des têtes mais
qu'ils sont pas fait ça sert à rien et
si on fait des tests et que c'est pas
donné aux épidémiologistes et qu'on en
reste au stade de notre cabinet ça sert
aussi à rien donc voilà ça fait trois
mois qu'on essaie de s'organiser dans
six mois on sera près six mois peut-être
la date malheureusement de la deuxième
vague catherine hill vous vous avez bien
précisé que pour vous la première vague
n'était pas terminée les cette fameuse
deuxième vague un peu virulente en
octobre en octobre c'est souvent ce qui
est ce qui est dit en tout cas à
l'automne vous vous y croyez ou vous
pouvez un petit peu nous rassurer ce
soir ben je peux ni vous rassurer ni
vous alarmer je vois pas pourquoi
l'épidémie ne reprendrait pas fin
juillet ou en août
si le virus est toujours là et si les
gens bougent pas mal ne font plus du
tout attention et en ont plus de chance
en bougeant de rencontrer des gens qui
n'ont pas rencontré la semaine dernière
et donc c'est comme un billet acheté
plus de billets de loterie plus vous
rencontrer des gens différents
+1 pour le risque vous avez le rythme
est tombé sur un quai porter est
contagieux donc c'est ça le truc on peut
pas du tout alors l'histoire de haute
pourquoi l'automne c'est parce que c'est
les gens pensent que ce virus
et comme les virus de la grippe et qu'il
est saisonnier mais vu qui a dû lire il
ya eu 10 virus depuis l'islande jusqu'à
hong kong qu'il est au nord de
l'amérique en amérique du nord otan qu
en amérique du sud
je vois vraiment pas où la saison est
complètement à l'envers je vois vraiment
pas qu'est ce qui permet de dire que ce
virus serait saisonniers je crois
beaucoup
le mode f1 vous sur cette deuxième vague
à l'automne annonce est strictement
impossible
il ne peut pas y avoir de deuxième vague
en août je pars en vacances
non mais effectivement toujours voilà la
même chose des masques les tests les
gestes barrière c'est ce qui nous
prémunir à bertrand legrand et ça sera
le mot de la fin pour vous oui il faut
vraiment faim faut continuer les gestes
barrière vraiment faim que chacun soit
raisonnable sur la question tant qu'on
n'a pas une à deux semaines sans aucun
test positif
évidemment qu'il faut continuer à avoir
les gestes barrière des masques et
mettez vos masques évidemment quand vous
êtes dans un lieu confiné fermé et ne le
retire et pas quand vous rentrez dans le
cabinet du médecin c'est si possible par
des c'est promis on vous laissera partir
en vacances merci également à vous
catherine hill d'avoir été en direct
avec vous sur rt france merci à vous
deux